and finally new rule now that Governor
Jerry Brown of California is signing
separate climate treaties with China in
defiance of our federal government
conservatives conservatives can't
complain they can't complain when our
local law enforcement refuses to
cooperate with Trump's deportation
squads they can't grouse about
California cities threatening to deny
contracts to any firm that helps build
the border wall they they can't get mad
because we're just following in a long
and hallowed conservative tradition
called states rights
[Applause]
it's just that now we're the state that
wants to be left alone
Mississippi didn't like what attorney
general Bobby Kennedy was doing in the
60s well I don't like what Jeff Sessions
is doing now the the script has
completely flipped from 50 years ago
when progressives ran the show in
Washington and it was alabama Governor
George Wallace who physically blocked
the door of the University of Alabama to
prevent black kids from enrolling he was
always screaming about states rights
which he used as justification for this
but that was then now the white
supremists are the federal government
and its liberal states that are under
siege from federal overreach we're
trying to defend our way of life here
and what we believe in we believe in
sanctuary cities and pollution controls
and legalized pot and gun control and
Obamacare and a woman's right to choose
and we're going to defend him
we've reveled now
[Applause]
we are the rebels now and now we get to
talk like this
would say something we don't much cotton
when federal government thinks it knows
better how to do things and we do here
in our state the mud flaps on my
electric car say coexist
[Applause]
yeah we don't need no outside agitators
with their make America great again caps
coming in here to our clean state and
telling us to take down our solar panels
or how to treat our interns here in our
state we use tiki torches the way
they're supposed to be used for lesbian
weddings on the beach
[Applause]
farm-to-table ain't just woods around
here
that's all heritage we pride ain't no
pesticides in our organic broccolini we
proud of gay sex and hot yoga we proud a
pioneering colonic irrigation you can
have my botox injection when you pry it
from my cold dead hands vaginal
rejuvenation today vaginal rejuvenation
tomorrow that's you know rejuvenation
forever
[Applause]
that meddling federal government in
Washington it wants to tell us who we
can marry and where we can P they were
coming here and segregate our restrooms
telling us who can pee well well my
daddy was transgender and his data
before him
[Applause]
here in LA County we wear our ball gowns
over our balls if we choose one little
thing he got them in a tented general up
Dan Washington my name is Jeff Sessions
and he said and I quote good people
don't smoke marijuana well there are
good people here mr. tennard general and
sometimes we just want to sit on all
porch and watch all grass grow
[Applause]